[موسيقى]
يروى ان صاحب مصنع في الصين وقف مذهولا
امام رفض تاجر عربي دعوته الى وليمه عشاء
فاخره ارادها تكريما له بعد توقيع صفقه
تجاريه كبيره معه سبب رفض التاجر العربي
الدعوه هو ان اللحم لا يذبح وفق الشريعه
الاسلاميه اما سبب
ذهول الاقتصادي الصيني فهو ان العربيه طلب
منه قبل ساعات قليله ان يكتب على صناعاته
الصينيه التي سيرسلها اليه عباره صنع في
المانيا
والخلاصه لا يكتفي الامتناع عن اكل لحوم
الحيوانات المحرمه فلحوم الناس ايضا حرام
تؤكل بغيبه او بغش كله حرام
الى العناوين
مفتي مصر السابق يترحم على محمد مرسي في
ذكرى رحيله
قارب الموت من شواطئ ليبيا الى سواحل
ايطاليا غرقه ام اغرق
استنفار واستنكار في وزاره التعليم
الفرنسيه بسبب صلاه الطلاب المسلمين
بعد الهجوم الدوليه على تجريمها المثليه
اوغندا مسرح لمجزره وحشيه
ام امريكيه تبكي ابنه مختله عقليا اغروها
بتغيير جنسها فانتحرت امام قطار
هجوم مجتمعي اردني على ناشطه نسويه
واتهامها بالخروج من المله
مرحبا في مثل هذه الايام قبل اربع سنوات
بث التلفزيون المصري الرسمي خبرا عاجلا
يعلن وفاه الرئيس السابق محمد مرسي بنوبه
قلبيه حاده عن ثمانيه وستين عاما خلال
جلسه محاكمته في مجمع سجون الطرى بقضيه
التخابر مع حركه حماس الفلسطينيه لهذه
المناسبه وللمره الاولى ترحم مفتي مصر
السابق وعضو مجلس اداره تنظيم المياه
والمجارير الحالي علي جمعه ترحم على
الرئيس مرسي رغم تصنيفه السيء يقول
لكن المفتي السابق برر ترحمه بانه تعلم
مؤخرا من الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي انقطاع
الخصومه عند الموت الساعه 9:30 صباحا
رئاسه الجمهوريه في عهد الرئيس محمد مرسي
وانا هستعير من رئيس الجمهوريه الالحادي
عبد الفتاح السيسي رحمه الله
ولولا انه نطقها انا ما كنتش هنطق يعني
لولا ان الرئيس السيسي بيقول بعد ما بعد
محمد مرسي يقول رحمه الله انا ما كنتش
هقولها لان زعلان قوي
لاني زعلان قوي والتصنيف بتاعه مش حلو
عندي لكن
هو الريس بيعلمنا انه خلاص انقطعت الخصومه
مهما كانت هذه الخصومه ما دام
الاجل قد جاء
[موسيقى]
الهلا
[تصفيق]
لقد شدوا الهمه وسد الرحال فجمعوا رفقه
عمرهم وجناه والقوا بهم وبانفسهم في مركب
صيد عتيق يتسع لبحارته وغله الغيب لكنهم
كانوا سبعمائه وخمسين مهاجرا من مصر
وسوريا وفلسطين وباكستان تركوا ضيق العيش
وراءهم فكان البحر امامهم ينتظر دفنهم دون
غسل او صلاه فمن فقد اكثر ممن انتشل حيا
او دون حياه في مثل هذه الماسي لطالما
انتقدنا السلطات وضيق افاقها لكننا اليوم
ندعو الحالمين بعيش يحسبونه رغيدا خلف
البحار ندعوهم لاي يكونوا فوق السلطه وفوق
الاوهام وفوق القدره على رمي اطفالهم في
لعبه البحر علمتني قوارب المقامرين بارواح
الناس وارزاقهم
هذه الصوره لمركب المهاجرين القادمين من
ليبيا دقائق قبل غرقه ما يقوله لنا
الناجون هو ان المركب غرق خلال المناوره
لخفر السواحليناني الذي كان يدفعه الى
مكان ما السلطات اليونانيه تؤكد ان
المهاجرين رفضوا اغافتهم وفضلوا التوجه
الى ايطاليا ومنظمات غير حكوميه تنتقد
سلوك خفر السواحل وبين النفي والتاكيد
تبقى عده اسئله دون اجابات واضحه لواحده
من اكبر الماسي التي يشهدها البحر المتوسط
خلال السنوات الاخيره يا جماعه
اين هم اللي غرقوا السفينه وهما اللي
قلبوا المركب والله والله والله
اليونان هم اللي قربوا المركب وهم بيشدوهم
هم اللي قلبوهم هم اللي موتوهم انا مش
همشي من هنا لما اخد جثه اخويا ليست المره
الاولى التي توجه فيها الاتهامات لليونان
باغراق قوارب الهجره غير النظاميه تركيا
سبق ان نشرت تسجيلات مصوره لتاكيد
اتهاماتها محاوله فاشله لعبور بحر ايجا
هذا الفيديو نشرته سلطات التركيه يظهر
مركبا مليئا بالمهاجرين وهم يتعرضون
لاطلاق نار من عناصر خفر سواحل اليونانيه
امر كذبته اثينا قبل ان تفكر اسره وحافظه
بالهجره اكانت نظاميه او غير ذلك نقدم لها
بطاقه عائله سوريه شردت في سعيها للهجره
المعاكسه من السويد الى سوريا رغم كل ماسي
سوريا راقي الايوب حقق حلمه الدفين قبل
سنوات قليله بهجره عائليه الى السويد
لينتهي به الامر في سجونها عقوبه له بعد
ادانته بخطف ابنتيه من مركز لرعايه
القاصرين
وارسالهما مع زوجته الى سوريا بعد ان
سحبهما جهاز السوسيال الاجتماعي من حضن
الابوين بحجه تلقيه بلاغا بعنف
قبل ان تفكر اسره محافظه بالهجره اسالوا
انفسكم هل تستطيعون تحمل تلقين حكومات
الغرب اطفالكم بالقوه ثقافه الجنس الثالث
والرابع والخامس والعاشر اذا لم تحترموا
المثليين فانتم لستم كنديين توبخ معلمه
كنديه تلامذه مسلمين لرفضهم المشاركه
بفعاليات لدعم المثليه وصبت غضبا هستيريا
على هؤلاء الاطفال الذين تعلموا في بيوتهم
على رفض الفاحشه منذ الصغر وهو تعليم
تحرمه الحضاره الغربيه الحديثه ما دعى
المجلس الوطني للمسلمين الكنديين الى
اصدار بيان يعتبر سلوك المعلمه معاديا
للاسلام
هل يستطيع المحافظون الحالمون بالهجره
تقبل هزه جمهوريه تزلزل وجودهم في فرنسا
اذا اقام ابنائهم صلاه الظهر جماعه في
وقتها بمدرسه ابتدائيه
وزير التربيه الفرنسيه اغمي عليه اوكاد
بعد علمه بصلاه الطلاب المسلمين التي
وصفها بالامر الخطير والذي لا يطاق وبانها
هجوم على العلمانيه التي تحكم فرنسا يعني
حيرتونا هل العلمانيه هي فصل الدين عن
السياسه ام فصل الدين عن الانسان وعن
الحياه تلاميذ مسلمون بمدارس ابتدائيه في
فرنسا صلوا جماعه بساحه المدرسه ثم وقفوا
دقيقه الصمت احياء لذكرى النبي محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم حدث كان كفيلا باحداث هزه
في فرنسا الدوله العلمانيه حتى وصل الامر
لفتح تحقيق وتدخل وزير التربيه الذي اعتبر
ان ما حدث في ثلاث مدارس بمدينه نيس حاله
تطرف وامر لا يطاق قبل ان يؤكد ان هناك
اجراءات اضافيه ستتخذ على المستوى الوطني
كما تم استدعاء الاباء لاتخاذ اجراءات
قانونيه وابلاغهم بان الامر سيواجه بحزم
هجمه النظم الاجتماعيه الغربيه المتفلته
والاجباريه لا تقتصر على المسلمين بل بدات
بالمسيحيين ام امريكيه تبكي ابنتها التي
انتزعت منها بعد اتهام السلطات لها بعدم
تقبل قرار ابنتها بالتحول الى صبي
ابنتي لم تكن لديها اضطرابات جنسيه تقول
بل كانت تعاني امراضا عقليه ونتيجه ثقافه
تحديد الجنس انتحرت
عذرا سيدتي فالرئيسك لون الاسبوع الماضي
بيته الابيض وطمان من وصفهم بالاطفال
العابرين جنسيا بان حريتهم بالتانيث او
الاسترجال مكفوله
اذا غلب على الفتاه المحجبه الحضور الجدي
يقولون انها متحجره لا تحب الحياه واذا
رقصت فرحا بتخرجها سترفض مديره مدرسه
امريكيه تسليمها الشهاده بذريعه الاخلال
بالجديه
[موسيقى]
نائبه استراليه تبكي في البرلمان اثناء
الروايتها التفاصيل ما قالت انه تعرضها
لاعتداء جنسيا من قبل رجال اقوياء روايه
احرجت احد زملائها الذي كذب الاتهام
[موسيقى]
الحريه المفتوحه في الغرب وجحافل نسويه
فيها لم تحمي سياسيه برلمانيه من اضطهاد
المراه ومن مشاريع الاغتصاب والتحرش فهل
تحتاج المنطقه العربيه الى تعديل ثقافتها
لصالح النموذج الاتي من الغرب يسال مراقب
تابع الضجه الكبيره التي احدثها في الاردن
اعلان لمنظمه اما اهل عن تنظيم دوره
لتعليم مبادئ النسويه بتقديم من الناشطه
هاله عاهد الهجوم المجتمعي الواسع والحاد
على الفكره ومروجيها اتهم النسويه بانها
قائمه على تدمير مفهوم العائله المحافظه
والمؤمن بالله وفقا لتغريدات رصدتها صحيفه
الوئام وفيها تكفير لهالا عاهد ودعوات الى
محاكمتها ونزع الجنسيه الاردنيه عنها
واستعاد الناشطون المناهضون للنسويه
تصريحات سابقه لها تخير فيها الاردنيين
بين تعديل فهمهم للشريعه الاسلاميه او وضع
الشريعه جانبا لصالح تشريعات تصفها
بالمدنيه علما ان التشريعات الدينيه ليست
عسكريه هي مدنيه ايضا اما نقيض التشريعات
الدينيه لغويا فهو التشريعات اللاتينيه
ببساطه نحن امام عده خيارات اما خيار ان
نطور التفسير الذي تم الاستناد اليه وان
ندور على اراء اكثر تنويرا داخل احكام
الشريعه الاسلاميه ونبحث عنها ليتطور
لدينا حتى النص التشريعي او ان نضع هذا
النص جانبا
ونذهب الى اطار الحقوق المدنيه بمعنى ما
نص عليه الدستور ومنص عليه الاتفاقيات
الدوليه هذا الخيارين اللي امامنا لكن ان
نبقى امام نصوص جامده كان الفقهاء وقتها
نظرتهم للعلاقه الزوجيه ليست كما ننظر
اليها الان معظم الفقهاء كانوا يتحدثوا عن
عقد الزواج بوصفه عقد يملك به الرجل بضع
المراه استعاد المعترضون على نشاط هاله ما
اعتبروه دفاعها عن مغتصب وقاتل طفله عمرها
اربع سنوات لانها نهضت اعدامه حيث انه
ارتكب جريمته في سن السابعه عشر علما ان
القانون لا يعذب مجرمي هذا السن لكنها لا
ترفض عقوبه الاعدام لكل الاعمار وتصفها
بانها قاسيه ولا انسانيه ولكن انا برايي
بانه الاعدام هو عقوبه قاسيه ولا انسانيه
وتنتهك الحق في الحياه اللي هو الذي حمته
الشرائع السماويه كافه وحمته الاتفاقيات
الدوليه شيخ المفسرين الامام محمد متولي
الشعراوي رحمه الله يشرح ان عقوبه قتل
القاتل في الاسلام جاءت لتمنع القتل وليس
لتوسيع دائرته لكن هل من اولي الباب اصحاب
عقول ليفهموا الحكمه الالهيه يسال ولكم في
القصاص حياه انظروا الى الدقه التي تحمل
الحيثيه
ياء للالباب وغير اولي الالباب هم الذين
يجادلون القصاص ونقتل ما بزياده فقد نوعه
هنفقد التاني ايه الوحشيه دي نقول له انت
عايز تخرج نفسك منقول الالباب اللي يقول
كده يبقى ما عندوش ايه ما عندوش لعلكم
تعقلون الحكمه في تقنين العقوبه لان
الحكمه في تقنين العقوبه
تقع الجريمه يبقى اذا خوف العقوبه هو اللي
عامل ايه هو اللي عامل التوازن التوازن في
المعسكرات العالم وبرضو خوفي العقوبه هو
اللي بيعمل التوازن في الافراد شبكه سي ان
الامريكيه سبق ان نشرت تقريرا تحت عنوان
ما هي الحركه النسويه العربيه ومن
العربيات اللواتي تراستها ووصفت سته نساء
برائدات النسويه كانت اخرهن نوال السعداوي
التي حرصت حتى الرمق الاخير على الدعوه
الصريحه الى الكفر بجميع الاديان يعني انا
طبيبه لك انت خصصت في الاديان عشان قضيه
المراه
والمراه مقهوره في جميع الادهان الاديان
ليه لكن هم طبقوا الاديان غلط لا لا اقرا
التوراه ما احنا انا مش عايزه اخدعك بقى
في اخر عمري انا مش عايزه ادور في الفلك
الذي يبرر الدين ان الدين الدين حلو قوي
ونظرياته عظيمه
ده الدين مش مبني على العدل هات التوراه
والانجيل والقران مش ده الدين اللاسطه
الاردنيه هاله عهد صرحت انها تختلف مع بعض
مدارس النسويات في العالم
فهل الاولى ان تكرس جهدها للرد على
الثقافه التي خلفتها الزعيمه نوال
السعداوي قبل غيرها لا سيما وان السعداوي
تعتبر المحجبات من زمن السيده مريم عليها
السلام الى كل محجبه حتى يوم الدين
تعتبرهن متخلفات وجسدا بالعقل بحسب
تعبيرها المشين استاذه فنان وتكنولوجي لبس
الحجاب تعتبر راسها عوره استاذ عميد كليه
بس هذه حريتها الشخصيه اليست حريه شخصيه
لا الحجاب يعني هو رمز سياسي خطير لعبوديه
المراه وان المراه جسد بدون عقل
[موسيقى]
في نواميس حكومه حزب بهارات يا جنات
الهنديه ليست الفتنه اضطهاد المسلمين
وقتلهم وتعذيبهم كما فعل ضباط ملثمون من
الشرطه جلدوا مسلمين في ولايه جوجرات بعد
اعتراضهم على بدء السلطات المحليه هدم
مسجد ومقبره بحجه مخالفتها قانون البناء
بل ان الشكوى من ذلك والدعوه الى السلام
والعداله هي المحظور هكذا علق متابعون على
قرار محكمه هنديه حضر حلقه برنامج المسافه
صفر في قناه الجزيره تحت عنوان الهند من
اشعل الفتيل بدعوى تحريضها على الكراهيه
فهل تعتبر المحكمه الهنديه اعتداء داميا
على رجلين مسلمين في الهند بتهمه الاشتباه
بترويجهما لحوم الابقار واكلها نوعا من
اشاعه المحبه والطاقه الايجابيه في البلاد
في جوار الهند في الباكستان وباكستان تعني
باللغه العربيه الارض الطاهره يحيي
المسلمون تقليدا مرتبطا بعيد الاضحى
المبارك حيث يقوم الميسورون بانزال
المواشي الاضاحي من على سطوح المباني حيث
تربى على مدار العام استعدادا للاحتفال
بسنن عيد الاضحى المبارك وذبح الاضاحي
وتوزيع لحومها على الفقراء وليس على مطاعم
الاغنياء
[موسيقى]
هو كانت امنيتو يموت في مكه او يعني فلفل
الحرمين الشريفين سبحان الله هو رايح
الطريق بما شاء في قلوه انا ما راح ارجع
كانت امنيته ان يتوفاه الله في جوار
الحربيد الشريفين وكان له ما تمنى الحاج
محمد حامد من الشمال السوري وبصيته
المؤثره لابنائه قبل ثلاث ساعات من وفاته
في ربوع مكه المكرمه
وان رضيان عليكم يا ابني
سامحني يا ابني انت واخواتك وامك وخالتك
والحمد لله يا ابني انا والله
بتشكرك بتشكرك
وانت مكفل بالجامع من بعدي انت واخوتك
بتخلصوهم وبتبيعوا الاراضي اللي عندي هوى
الضياع وبتكملوا
[موسيقى]
والدار اللي سامرتها
للامام يا ابني والموت وحق والبنات ما
بتحرموهن من حقهم يا ابني
الله يعطيك العافيه والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
حاجه مصريه رات في وجه شاب خليجي ذكرى
ابنها المتوفى حديثا فابكتها الذكرى وادب
الشاب الخلوق
كان عندها ولد تذكرت للحين الله اكبر
تجتمعوا ان شاء الله في الجنه ان شاء الله
ويغفر لولد ويجمع بكم في جنات النعيم
لك يا رب
الله المستعان الله المستعان
وان شاء الله اجيك في مصر
[موسيقى]
ختاما عن ابي ذر رضي الله عنه قال قلت يا
رسول الله الا تستعملني قال فضرب بيده على
منكب ثم قال يا ابا ذر انك ضعيف وانها
امانه وانها يوم القيامه خزي وندامه الا
من اخذها بحقها وادى الذي عليه فيها صدق
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
معنى الضعف الوارد في الحديث فسره العلماء
بانه العجز عن القيام بوظائف الولايه
وبهذا المعنى كان ابو ذر ضعيفا اما اباء
المقدره الذريه في بعض دول ازمنه غابره
فهم اقوى من فرعون لكن دولهم اضعف من
اماره موناكو الى اللقاء لاج
قلدت ظاهر ما فيهم فبدوت شخصا اخر
كي اتفاخر
وظننت انا اني بذلك حست غنى فوجدت اني
خاسر فتلك مظاهر
[موسيقى]